YOUR LIFE AND THANK YOU FOR
CONTINUING TO REPORT ON THIS FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> TUCKER: CHARLIE KIRK IS
SOMEONE ELSE WHO APPARENTLY WAS
CENSORED BY TWITTER, FOUNDER AND
PRESIDENT OF TURNING POINT USA.
WE JUST TOLD YOU THAT BARI WEISS
JUST REPORTED THAT TWITTER SET
CHARLIE'S ACCOUNT TO DO NOT
AMPLIFY STATUS.
HE JOINS US RIGHT NOW.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
YOU'RE JUST HEARING THIS, TOO.
THIS JUST HAPPENED, THIS IS
HAPPENING, IN FACT, AS WE TALK
ABOUT IT.
>> YES.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHICH OF
YOUR TWEETS SET THE CENSORSHIP
IN MOTION?
>> I COULD PROBABLY GUESS.
YOU KNOW, A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO,
AXIOS DID A STUDY THAT SHOWED
OUR TWITTER ACCOUNT IT WAS
FOURTH MOST ENGAGED ON THE
PLANET, RIGHT UP THERE WITH
TRUMP.
I HAD BEEN USING IT FOR A
DECADE, UNDERSTOOD IT REALLY
WELL AND WE WERE AVERAGING
115,000 RETREATS EACH DAY AT OUR
PEAK AND WE WERE TALKING ABOUT,
FOR EXAMPLE, IN THE MIDST OF THE
VIRUS HOW LOCKDOWNS MAY NOT BE
THE BEST DECISION.
WE STARTED ASKING THE QUESTION,
ARE THERE OTHER TREATMENTS WE
MIGHT WANT TO TALK ABOUT.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN THAT.
THEN WE SAW, OFF A CLIFF ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY, OUR ENGAGEMENT AND
RETWEETS DISAPPEAR.
I STARTED TO TALK ABOUT THIS A
LOT AND I WAS CALLED A
CONSPIRACY THERE IT.
I WAS SMEARED AND I STARTED AN
EMAIL.
>> TUCKER: YOU'RE CRAZY.
>> YOU'RE Q-ANON.
I USED TO GET A HUNDRED THOUSAND
RETWEETS AND THEY CONVINCE YOU
TO STOP TALKING ABOUT IT, WHO
CARES ABOUT YOUR TWITTER
ACCOUNT, NOT A BIG DEAL AND NOW
YOU SEE ACTUAL VERIFIED
DOCUMENTS WHERE MY TWITTER
ACCOUNT WAS LABELLED AS DO NOT
AMPLIFY, WHICH I COULD ONLY
INFER MEANS NOT SAFE FOR WORK.
SAFE TAGS.
THEY WERE TREATING MY ACCOUNT
WITH MORE SCRUTINY AND
CENSORSHIP THAN THE PRIME
MINISTER OF IRAN, THAN HAMAS,
THAN PEOPLE WHO DO ACTUAL
TERRORISTIC TYPE DAMAGE.
THEY SAW WHAT I HAD TO SAY AS A
DIRECT THREAT TO THE REGIME.
>> TUCKER: THERE IS A HUGE
AMOUNT OF UNFILTERED HARD-CORE
PORN ON TWITTER TO THIS DAY BUT
IT WAS YOUR TWITTER ACCOUNT THAT
WAS NOT SAFE FOR WORK.
>> APPARENTLY.
APPARENTLY.
ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR
LOCKDOWN POLICY, WHICH,
OBVIOUSLY, HURT CHILDREN AND
HURT OUR TARGET AUDIENCE AT
TURNING POINT USA COLLEGE KIDS
WHERE THEY HAD TO GO HOME AND
STARE AT A SCREEN ALL DAY LONG.
I STARTED TWEETING ABOUT THAT.
APPARENTLY THAT WAS A THREAT.
MY QUESTION, THOUGH, TUCKER IS,
WERE THEY TOLD TO DO THIS BY
ANTHONY FAUCI?
WERE THEY TOLD TO DO THIS BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT?
WERE MY TWEETS SOMEHOW ABLE TO
CREATE VIRAL COUNTERMESSAGING TO
WHAT THEY WANTEDED TO SEE HAPPEN
IN 2020?
WE MAY NEVER KNOW, BUT TWITTER
AT ITS BEST, WHEN IT WAS REALLY
SOMETHING THAT WAS WORTHY OF
APPRECIATION, I HOPE IT GETS
THERE SOON, WAS A PLACE WHERE
OPPOSITE IDEAS WERE ABLE TO
SPREAD AND RALLY AND HOLD PEOPLE
POWERFUL ACCOUNTABLE.
I HAPPENED TO HAVE ONE OF THOSE
ACCOUNTS FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS
AND TWITTER WENT OUT OF THEIR
WAY TO CENSOR IT.
>> TUCKER: LET ME ASK YOU, DID
YOU COMPLAIN, YOU UNDERSTOOD THE
PLATFORM SO YOU KNEW SOMETHING
FAKE WAS HAPPENING, SOMEONE WAS
PUTTING A THUMB ON THE SCALE,
DID YOU COMPLAIN TO TWITTER
ABOUT IT?
>> YES, I DID.
I HAD A VERY WARM MEETING WITH
SOME OF THE TWITTER EMPLOYEES, I
ACTUALLY MET WITH JACK DORSEY
PERSONALLY WHO ASSURED ME SHADOW
BANNING WASN'T HAPPENING, I
WASN'T EXPERIENCING A LOT OF
WHAT WE CONSIDERED CENSORSHIP,
AND THEN SIX TO 12 MONTHS LATER,
I STARTED TO WRITE THEM,
SOMETHING IS NOT RIGHT HERE,
SILENCE, AND THEN THE VIRUS
HAPPENED IN 2020 AND COULD YOU
NOT GET A RESPONSE OUT OF
TWITTER.
AND THEN WOULD YOU START TO
TWEET AT JACK AND TWEET AT THE
TWITTER MANAGEMENT, AND IT WAS
ALMOST AS IF IT BECAME A WHOLLY
OPERATED COMPANY THAT KIND OF
CHANGED THEIR MODUS OPERANDI
FROM BEING SOMEWHAT OF A SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORM TO A SUPER PAC
AND I DON'T THINK THEY CARED.
ELON, PRAISE GOD FOR HIS COURAGE
AND BRAVERY REVEALING.
THIS I TRIED TO GET LAWMAKERS
INVOLVED AND OTHER PEOPLE.
I DON'T THINK WE'LL BE ABLE TO
MEASURE THE IMPACT OF WHAT
TWITTER DID TO OUR LIVES.
THE LIVES LOST, THE KIDS FROM
SCHOOL CLOSURES AND THE OUTCOME
OF THE 2020 ELECTION ALL CAME
FROM A CENSORSHIP OF TWITTER.
>> TUCKER: AND THEY DID IT LAST
WEEK PARTLY BECAUSE EVERYONE
THAT WORKS THERE IS A LIBERAL,